Democrats proclaim they are ushering in
a revolution and insist you join but
they're not actually assuring a
revolution in meanwhile some good news
on coronavirus maybe and bench grow this
is the bench Bureau show today's show is
sponsored by expressvpn stand up for
your digital rights take action right
now at expressvpn dot-com /ban we're
gonna get to all of the news in just one
second cuz there is a lot of news and a
lot of narrative being driven a lot of
narrative being driven most of it false
we're gonna get to that in just one
second first you may have noticed that
this is a crazy time I mean a crazy ton
because the stock market has been
bouncing around like a yo-yo over the
past several months you don't know
what's going to happen next I mean
there's a twist and turn around every
corner in this season six of Trump it's
pretty incredible that means that you
probably want to make sure that you have
banked against the possibility of a
downturn that you you've made the
diversification decision you should have
made months ago and if you had you'd be
a lot wealthier today I'm talking of
course about diversify into precious
metals with 40 million people unemployed
and six trillion dollars already spent
on kovat 19 well inflation is probably
on the way sometime in the not so far
future and this is why among many other
reasons it is a good idea to have some
of your money in precious metals and the
people I trust as you know with my
precious metals investing Birch gold
group texts been to 47 47 47 right now
when you purchase on or before July 31st
when you get a precious metals IRA you
get a free signed copy of my book the
right side of history Birch gold will go
to work for you and make things super
simple ask all of your questions get all
of your answers be a fully informed
investor text my name Ben - 47 47 47 and
at least request a free information kit
on diversifying into gold there's no
obligation Birch gold group has
thousands of satisfied customers
countless five-star reviews and a plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
so protect yourself the way that I've
protected myself diversify you got to
make sure that your asset base is
diversified tax Ben - 47 47 47 during
the months of June or July when you open
an IRA in precious metals you get a
signed copy of my New York Times number
one best-selling book the right side of
history for free again text Ben - 47 47
47 text my name Ben - 47 47 47 alrighty
so what is happening right now
is pretty astonishing across the country
the basic message is that you will be
forced to kneel and if you do not need
then you'll be castigated as racist when
I say Neal I don't just mean physically
Neal I mean that you will be forced to
parrot the messages that the radical
left would like you to pair it about
race in the United States and those
messages are things like you as a white
person bear inherent guilt for the sins
of the past that you may not have done
anything racist but you yourself are
implicitly racist and you're part of the
problem
you're supposed to parent notions like
the police are systemically racist and
this explains all inequality in arrest
numbers you're supposed to believe that
America has a 400 year unbroken history
of victimizing black Americans not that
slavery was evil not the Jim Crow is
evil but that today is just a continuum
and it's just a continuation of past
policy in the United States and
therefore again all inequality can be
chalked up to inequity and if you fail
to recognize any of this then this is
because you suffer from white privilege
that white privilege can only be
expunged by repeating the messages that
you're supposed to repeat so you are
supposed to silence is violence you're
not supposed to keep silent you're not
supposed to shut your mouth you're
supposed to pair it exactly what the
left one wants you to say because
silence is violence and if you say
something that the left does not want
you to say well then as we know speech
is violence so silence is violence and
speeches violence unless you act as
basically a stenographer for the most
radical left protesters and then suggest
that you are on the same side now that
will not buy you off right you can do
all of that but if you are the
Minneapolis mayor and you break from the
radical left at any point here well then
you will be eaten by the mob right that
is the that is the threat that is
implicit here and it's now pervaded all
of society and this is why you see so
many corporations going out of their way
to put out incredible statements
suggesting that no I'm the most
anti-racist no I'm the most anti-racist
well what have you said about George
Floyd today I'm the most anti-racist now
again this is completely unnecessary
these statements the reason it's
unnecessary is not because anybody is in
favor of what happened to George Floyd
it's because everybody is not in favor
of what happened to George Floyd
Americans don't feel the need is a
general rule to point out when a hundred
percent of Americans agree that
something is evil that something is evil
because we all agree right there's no
controversy as I've said before there
are no protests today with people
shouting the sky is blue because nobody
actually believes that the sky is not
blue nobody actually believes that black
lives don't matter so the black lives
matter protests are a suggestion tacitly
that there is a group of people who
actively believe that black lines
do not matter that is one of the open
suggestions that have been made Ashton
Kutcher has said as much right he says
the reason we protest for black lives
matter is because there are so many
Americans who believe that black lives
do not matter but there's no evidence of
that
there's really no evidence that lots and
lots of Americans believe black lives
don't matter so what is this really
about it's about driving the underlying
narrative that America is inherently
evil that America is inherently bad and
that if you fuse to recognize that
America is inherently evil and
inherently bad and that the system is
corrupt to top to bottom well then
obviously you are part of the problem I
have to read you a an email that went
out from one of these corporations
because it really is astonishing it's an
email from a small company I assume
called Memphis rocks climbing it was
sent to me by one of our listeners a few
days ago this from June 2nd and the
subject is st. George Floyd that is the
the subject of the email it says eight
days ago st. George Floyd was killed in
front of the world yes we call him st.
George now not because he was perfect as
we must understand Saints to be but
because like st. George of England who
struggled a fire-breathing dragon that
was the devil today's Saint George
struggled with the devil of
discrimination he struggled to the
fire-breathing dragon that like all fire
stole his oxygen and robbed him of his
breath of life none of us here at
Memphis rocks knew st. George personally
but our guess is he might have shouted I
can't breathe on any given day to an
American that had cut off AK and they
had cut off the oxygen for so many of
his kin the oxygen of opportunity of
equality of access right this is a
religious statement I mean they're
literally calling him a saint this is it
this is a religious statement now again
I'm not gonna jump on the whole getting
into singing into George Floyd's
background or his personal life or the
crimes he had committed in the past day
I don't think it's relevant to what the
officer did in this particular case the
officer committed an atrocity and that's
why George Floyd is dead according to
medical examiner reports everybody wants
the guy in jail the key here is the
email right the email is basically
suggesting a religious revival around
all of this and the religious principle
that you will be made to to repeat is
that America is consistently cutting off
the oxygen of opportunity equality and
access for black Americans and not just
that you are supposed to accept
responsibility for all of this so as
Memphis rocks I'm only reading this
because this is very representative of
an entire group of emails that I've been
going out corporations and wrestling
amounts of their employees if you don't
then people get mad at you
the local gym in the area and somebody
contacted me they said somebody called
and cancelled out their membership today
because we had not put out a statement
at all right silence was violence and so
they cancelled their gym membership
because they like I wasn't aware that
were consumers who did this sort of
thing right if they if you don't send a
statement about a topic completely
unrelated to your business then they
cancel their membership but apparently
that is a thing
according to Memphis rocks officer
shavon was not the only one who murdered
st. George Floyd any of us who still
harbored racist attitudes no matter how
subtle we bear some of the weight of the
knee on his neck you are guilty right
this is a religious this is a religious
call any of us who are heirs to the
benefits of enslaving of people upon
whose backs we built our nation of
people who are then tonight equal access
to the very benefits we reaped we bear
some of the weight of the knee on his
neck any of us who see no evil in the
concentration of wealth in the hands of
so few while so many have so little we
bear some of the weight of the knee on
his neck right so this is the call for
revolution that it's a class revolution
that if you do not believe that it is
evil for people to be rich in the United
States of America then you are guilty of
the murder of George Floyd the emails
openly saying this is going to one
family Memphis and the Memphis rocks
team it is no accident all of this is
happening the midst of a pandemic the
Kovach crisis and the murder of st.
George Floyd are not separate the entire
world wears masks now each face
metaphorically screaming I can't breathe
and no wonder we are not living in
accordance with got in accord with God's
creation choking her skies soiling her
rivers labeling her diverse beautiful
people as other can you not hear the
Godhead herself crying out precisely
perfectly at this moment I can't breathe
today's news is not new racial divisions
have been plaguing us for centuries
what's new has to be us we must move
from domination to collaboration we must
abandon the winner of loser model
embrace the philosophy of family all is
a brotherhood and a sisterhood we are
George Floyd and George Floyd is us
until that day is realized we will all
remain masked and none of us will be
able to truly breathe so that this is
from a I believe a rock climbing company
Memphis rocks or or it is from one
family yes Rock Memphis rocks climbing
and community so that's what this is you
know that is a religious revival as
message right this is a tenth meeting
revival
message that's that's what that is right
there and that message is now being put
forth to all Americans that you are
guilty of George Floyd's murder you
didn't do anything you'll pose the
murder you think it's evil doesn't
matter
don't say exactly what people in the
media would love for you to say and what
Democratic politicians would love for
you to say then they will come after you
and if you are a if you are a protest
leader if you do not say exactly what a
protest leader wants to say then they
will come after you even if you're a
Democrat or a media leader it is this
the way to end racism in America I have
serious doubts is this a way to make
America more unified around things that
were already unified around like
violence is wrong looting is wrong
racism is wrong police brutality is one
hundred percent agreed on all of these
things but this is not designed to be a
time of unification this is designed to
be a time of division by accusing at
least half of Americans of being tacitly
racist if they refuse to endorse the
most radical messages about the remaking
of America okay this is made explicit in
a in a column today by Dana Millbank
over at the Washington Post called
Trump's Republican Party displays it's
systemic racism this is the narrative
it's being driven so how are they
displaying their systemic racism because
Senator Tom cotton who claims there's no
structural racism in law enforcement
which is true there is no there's no
evidence that law enforcement bodies all
over America are structurally racist
there are races who are in law
enforcement statistics do not bear out
the idea that the police are targeting
black people kua black people that they
are just targeting black people because
they're black there's no statistical
evidence for this as in none that does
not mean that they're they're not
racists who are out there and police
forces doing bad things but overall the
idea that police forces around America
are rounding up black people posing an
existential threat to black people it's
not true again does that mean that there
aren't enormous number of bad run-ins
between police officers and black
Americans of course that's true of
course that's true but to attribute that
to the innate racism of quote-unquote
structures is deliberately vague and
that's sort of the purpose here right
when you're deliberately vague about
what you're accusing people of then they
can't deny it
see if you accuse somebody of being
involved in systemic or structural
racism there's no way for them to deny
it because they can say but I'm not
racing yeah but I wasn't accusing you I
was accusing the structure what
structure were you accusing the
structure of America which institution
America which Americans every American
who is white and has benefited from the
system but now you're accusing me again
no I wasn't accusing you like it's just
this circular game
that's the
purpose okay so according to Dana
Millbank because Tom cotton suggested
that the US military quash rioting and
looting this means he's a racist and
listen to how Dana Millbank twists the
message he says the Tom cotton is a
racist because he called for a quote
overwhelming show of force unquote by
the US military to quash racial unrest
it was not the quashed racial unrest it
was to quash rioting and looting he
specifically said if you're protesting
against police brutality or even against
systemic police racism he disagrees with
of course he shouldn't call in the
military on that this prompted House
Majority Whip Jim Clyburn African
American product of the segregated south
and Democrat from South Carolina to port
Alexis de Tocqueville the greatness of
America lies not in being more
enlightened than any other nation but
rather in her ability to repair her
fault
and then Clyburn says Cotton's from
Arkansas if you ought to be ashamed of
himself ah
because Arkansas has a racist past that
means that Tom cotton ought to be
ashamed of himself because apparently he
is just a product of that past in his
tacitly racist and so Dana Millbank says
it was good to see Democrats back in the
fight they've been largely out of the
debate for the past couple of months
because the House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
decided not to convene during the
pandemic presumptive presidential
nominee Joe Biden broadcasting from his
basement didn't know better they should
be rushing to engage this battle for as
the nation grapples with George Floyd's
killing and what to do about persistent
police brutality this much has become
clear there's structural racism in the
Republican Party structural racism in
the Republican Party what is his
evidence of this that there was a
Republican chairman in Texas who shared
racist stuff that means structural
racism by the way you know who doesn't
get mentioned anywhere in here Steve
King who just got primary doubt of his
seat in Iowa because people like me
maxed out to his opponent Kevin
finnstrom and then they say I love this
from Dana Millbank this is not the
Republican Party a former president
george w bush who last week called for
america to examine our tragic failures
okay i'm old enough to remember when you
call them a racist over hurricane
katrina
you're on the left so i don't buy your
newfound respect for the anti racism of
george w bush i think you're full of
crap they say it's not the party of
senator mitt romney says says dana
Milbank the 2012 Republican presidential
nominee who nobly marched with black
lives matters demonstrators on Sunday
yeah I'm old enough to remember when Joe
Biden accused him of wanting to put
people black and back in Chains black
people back in Chains so no I don't buy
your nonsense but this is the narrative
the narrative is Republicans are racist
the Democrats are consistently pushing
this narrative it makes it difficult to
push that narrative on the back of an
issue where we all agree
like George Floyd was killed in an
atrocity and the officer should go to
jail if we all agree on that you can't
say right but we agree on that but
you're a racist you can't do that
instead you have to generate
disagreement the way to generate
disagreement is to draw a broader
narrative and make extreme demands of
human behavior and then if people don't
participate then you say that they are a
racist
and this is deeply affective stuff
because as the media keep repeating over
and over and over again that black
Americans are victimized by law
enforcement what you are seeing is that
America's Americans tend to believe it i
Rasmussen has a new poll informed the
Washington Examiner
that 51 percent believe that black
people generally receive unfair
treatment by the police only 32 percent
disagree blacks seventy percent are a
lot more likely than whites 47 percent
and other minority voters 53 percent to
think black Americans receive unfair
treatment from the police the survey
found that 36 percent of Americans
believe police discrimination is a
bigger problem than crime in low-income
inner-city areas 36 of Americans
fifty-three percent disagree
first of all you're insane if you
believe that police discrimination is a
bigger problem than crime and low income
in inner-city areas that's it that's it
that is a nutty position it is nuts if
you were worried about lack of
investment in inner-city communities if
you're worried about lack of a tax base
crime is significantly a bigger problem
then quote-unquote police discrimination
in these inner-city communities by the
way you removed police from those
communities that's what caused according
to many sociologists the spike in crime
in inner-city communities in the first
place there's been a wide differential
in crime statistics between black and
white in America for well over a hundred
years and one of the reasons for that is
because white America said you're on
your own
police ourselves and it didn't work
there's a great book called ghetto side
by Jane lady who's a left-leaning
reporter for the LA Times she points out
remove the police from these communities
and what you can expect is an uptick in
lawlessness but again the idea here is
that the police are the problem if you
believe that the police are the problem
rather than solution to high crime good
luck to you but this is this is the
symbolism and it's all symbolism at this
point and what we are in a symbolic
fight because it's not about policy as
we will see and the Democrats are fully
willing to engage in the symbolism of
America is brutal evil and vicious just
so long as then enough to do anything
the protesters want that's that that's
the exploitative revolution here yes
we're on your side we're further
evolution we're gonna kneel like it's
Wakanda we're gonna wear these Kente
quads we're gonna we're gonna
like the white people from get out
that's we're gonna do every single Bay
and we're we're on your side man we're
on your side and then oh yeah you want
us to defund the police that's crazy
that is the Democratic gen we're gonna
get to all of that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that
having a good HR department is the key
to running a great company you cannot
afford if you're running a company to
not be staffed up on HR you can't you
can't afford not to have an HR
department because one lawsuit can
really put you in a difficult position
HR issues can absolutely suck up time
that can suck up money they can kill you
but can you afford like an HR manager at
$80,000 a year or $70,000 a year instead
right now in this economy why and go
check out Bambi it's Belle ba MBE who's
created specifically for small business
you can get a dedicated HR manager craft
HR policy maintain your compliance all
for just $99 a month with Bambi
you can change HR from your biggest
liability to your biggest strength your
dedicated HR manager is available by
phone email real-time chat from on
boarding determinations they customize
your policies to fit your business and
help you manage your employees day to
day all for just $99 a month
month-to-month no hidden fees cancel
anytime
you didn't start your business because
you wanted to spend time on HR
compliance you didn't we've had HR
issues in my company we have to staff up
on HR there's no reason that you should
have to spend a fortune on HR when you
can use Bambi go to Bambi comm slash
Shapiro right now schedule your free HR
audit get your HR in line Bambi comm
slash capiro be a em to the BAE comm
slashing ship here I'll go check them
out right now and get all your HR
department issues
ironed right now okay so this is all
become symbolic now because this is no
longer about what policies ought to be
utilized in order to curb police
brutality this is no longer become about
saving lives in in black inner cities
this isn't about that because removing
police from those inner cities ain't
gonna save lives it's gonna cost lives
is we're gonna talk about in a second
it's all about the symbolism and the
symbolism crosses streams the broader
left its narrative that America and
Western civilization more generally are
tremendously tremendously evil and it
starts with sort of things we all agree
on and then it moves to things that we
absolutely disagree on so for example
there's been this real push to tear down
Confederate statutes now this has been a
long time push on the political left in
the United States and I understand the
appeal the Confederacy was evil the
Confederacy was fighting on behalf of
slavery I
and I definitely agree with the idea
that taxpayer dollars being used to to
uphold Confederate statues statues of
Confederate leaders that's in that
negative I think but the question is as
kind of Lee to rise put it whether you
rip away the history so that you're
never forced to confront the history and
we keep hearing from the left that we
should confront the history well maybe
it seems to me you might want to
confront the history by being able to
point to the bad people the statue of
the bad man say in this country these
people were treated as heroes for a
hundred years and four decades before
that and that's one of the things that
we've we need to move past is one like
having the reminder of America's evils
from the past is a good way of teaching
people about the past and also why we've
moved beyond it instead people are
seeking to tear down statues and then
they are seeking to conflate all
historic figures so for example London
okay there's a picture there not just
tearing down the statues of old
Confederate generals in London they
defaced a statue of Abraham Lincoln it
faced a statue of Abraham Lincoln with
BLM and the names of various people who
had been who died in police custody or
been killed by police including people
like Mike Brown I am Eddie at wit's end
to understand why it is that the black
lives matter movement wants to lump all
of these folks together because not all
these cases are the same they are not
the Michael Brown case was nothing like
the Eric garner case which was nothing
like debris on a Taylor case which was
nothing like the falando Castille case
like all of these cases are very
different many of these cases are true
atrocities and some of these cases like
Michael Brown are absolutely not
atrocities he was justifiably killed by
the police officer in that particular
case lumping all these people together
is a cheap trick and then to deface a
statue of Abraham Lincoln the great
Emancipator with these slogans is insane
there's a sign hanging around the around
the waist of Abraham Lincoln's statue in
London that said we need a new world and
that's exactly the point for these
revolutionaries tear down the past
people were defacing pictures defacing
statues of Winston Churchill Winston
Churchill right who fought the Nazis and
helped overcome the Nazis somebody's he
faced his statue in the middle of London
and they crossed out his name and then
says Churchill was a racist now there's
a lot of controversy over the level of
Winston Churchill's bigotry but if what
you took away from history
that Winston Churchill was a racist it's
because you're a dumbass if that is his
great contribution to humanity just like
Abraham Lincoln needs to be two-faced
and what you're really talking about is
the the defacement of all of Western
civilization if winkin and Churchill
ain't good enough for you to have
statues then no one is and that of
course is the point because no one
really is right the idea is the world
must be remade in real time and that
that is because the system is so deeply
and thoroughly corrupt that it must be
torn down and this is why you see the
push from members of the left in the
media in our political class to suggest
that racism in the United States is
still so much of a threat that it is
deadlier than an ongoing pandemic
deadlier than an ongoing pandemic okay
that's fully insane this pandemic has
killed at this point a hundred and
twenty thousand people in the United
States since the beginning of March is
just the beginning of June so in three
months we have a pandemic that is killed
a hundred and twenty thousand people
with full lockdown and we have been told
that if you go to your business and go
to your church if you go visit grandma
in the nursing home if you what if you
go and you go to death bed of Grandma
that you're gonna kill Americans unless
you're protesting racism protesting
racism is so necessary because America
is so evil and Western civilization is
so evil that it is that racism is a
greater threat to Americans and America
in 2020 not in 1865 not in 1965 in 2020
that you should go and you should spread
the virus widely among other protesters
to fight racism here's an NBC News
anchor trying to push this yesterday I
was out with other physicians and nurses
in Seattle over the weekend what we
added doctors for justice March and what
we were redoing we were passing out
masks we're making sure if you didn't
have a mask and you had a megaphone you
were protected I said some of my
colleagues were handing up Carell we
want as much as anything for social
justice to take center stage because
poverty racism they actually they have
actually bigger killer than coronavirus
by the statistics so this is the right
thing to do but to do it safely so masks
all the time social disease you can do
it okay so a couple of things there
poverty and racism are not the same
thing second of all if you cared so much
about poverty maybe you should have
thought about the giant lockdowns before
you put 40 million Americans out of work
but you weren't allowed to talk about
that were you but raises it so what he's
really saying is
his ability killer than coronavirus I'm
gonna need like a shred of evidence for
that Phil Murphy the governor of New
Jersey
he's trying to extend lockdown for
another 30 days meanwhile he got tested
for coronavirus yesterday because he was
out protesting with people we're gonna
get to this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you might
think be thinking yourself in a time
like this can I still get life insurance
the answer is yes you can you have to go
over to policy genius.com
right now as an insurance marketplace
policy genius is in contact with life
insurance companies on their platform
every day they're keeping track of all
the changes in the market so you don't
have to which means they can get you
covered quickly and for the best price
here is how it works
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork you could say 1500
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free so
if you hit any speed bumps during the
application process they will be there
to help walk you through the entire
process honestly if you are a decent
human being and you wanna make sure your
family is taken care of you really have
no choice but to go check out some life
insurance policy genius.com policy
genius will find you the best raise
handle the process completely they'll
get you and your family protected
hopefully give you one less thing to
worry about go check them out right now
at policy genius.com
again that is policy genius.com get life
insurance auto insurance disability
insurance meet all your insurance needs
today at policy genius.com okay so
because all of this is symbolic and the
symbolism is about how horrible American
racism is on a continuing level you have
politicians simultaneously claiming that
if you go outside you will die and kill
grandma in the process but also fighting
racism is so big and so important and so
endemic to American culture that if you
kill a lot of people well you still
wanted killed as many people as racism
which is a hell of an argument I mean at
some point you're gonna have to show me
it's amazing there are people who are
talking about ending lock down because
they were pointing out suicide Rises
opioid deaths people without a job die
deaths have despaired their kids suffer
you can't nope no hey come on come on
yeah Andrew Cuomo said death is the only
thing that we are worried about right
now we are not worried about any of
those other issues but if you just say
racism kills more people than
coronavirus with no evidence none zero a
grand total of according to the
Washington Post 15 black men were killed
unarmed by the police in 2019 and many
of those
running away from the cops and the
classification there is not particularly
clear Hey then I don't know it's tell
you there's no statistical evidence this
is just a religious appeal it is a root
religious appeal so here is Phil Murphy
making the come-to-jesus call that you
should brave death in order to fight
racism because it's just so important
this is a moment in time perhaps unlike
any in our nation's history there is an
overwhelming amount of anger and passion
and by the way it's all been incredibly
peaceful I mean overwhelmingly so
particularly in New Jersey and we should
be very proud of that I I can't imagine
what it would look like if we said to
people actually you have to you have to
stay in we you have to ignore systemic
racism I'm sorry for for just ignore it
just stay inside you can't go out and
voice just voice your your your anger
your rising
I can't omit looks like this is crazy
towns you literally told everybody to
give up their life savings in their
business and stay inside and watch their
parents die in a hospital
alone you literally told people they
cannot visit their relatives you
literally told people that if they
protest it against any of this they were
violating your lockdown order they
couldn't go to church or synagogue but
couldn't we tell people not to go out in
the streets and yell about George Floyd
without any actual policy ramifications
of course we can't do that of course we
can't - it's just that important to say
that America is terrible and evil and
racist it's just that important it
really isn't because remember when we
get to as you will see this is the
message and the way can tell this is the
message is that the specific policy
demands made by black lives matter
protesters are being completely ignored
by Democrats it is all about the
symbolic adoption of the language
without the actual adoption of any of
the policy so the Democrats we're doing
yesterday so last I checked Democrats in
Congress they're supposed to be passing
legislation right now legislations
helped fix the systemic racism of the
United States what were they actually
doing Nancy Pelosi is a terrible Speaker
of the House but Nancy Pelosi is very
good at coordinating outfits with the
rest of the Democratic with the
Democratic Power Rangers here so Nancy
Pelosi at the State of the Union address
she got everybody up in white right all
the women were wearing white to
demonstrate the purity of feminism well
now she got everybody at Kente cloth
which by the way like if everybody in
Congress showed up wearing a tallest one
day I'd be like what in the world are
you doing what do you think you are
doing all these
old white people putting on Kente cloth
to symbolize how much they care about
black Americans how do you not find this
culturally appropriate imagine if Mitt
Romney has done the scent of black lives
matter protest you think today would
have left there unscathed by the media
like does anyone think this mean when I
got old white Democrats like Nancy
Pelosi putting on a Kente cloth and
kneeling for George Floyd the best part
of this is that she then could not get
up I'm not kidding because these are old
white people who have done nothing to
solve the problems they say that they
have that exist in America they're so
deep and so endemic and so root that you
have to protest during a pandemic and
widely spread a deadly virus you need to
do all of that it's so important also
we've spent 50 years running Congress
and we and we haven't done anything but
at least we're kneeling for you by the
way if you get bought off by this you're
a sucker seriously if you believe that
Democrats are solving systemic racism
because they work hence a cloth you're a
sucker you're an unbelievable sucker and
there's one born every minute apparently
this is such cheap posturing as soon as
this I'm I'm all on board with President
Trump shouldn't have done a photo-op at
a church a burned-out church with a
Bible this is a photo-op
what do you call this when you have a
bunch of old white Democrats who can
barely get down on one knee wearing
Kente cloth looking like as one person
is where to put it chess pieces from a
Wakanda Black Panther chess set it's
absurd it's absurd on every level hey
here's what it looked like when
Democrats took me in Congress and then
answer Pelosi couldn't get up which was
kind of hilarious again just
underscoring she's been in Congress
forever and has gotten zero things done
but she's virtue signaling to you she's
signaling you here was Nancy Pelosi not
being able to get up
there needs eight minutes in 46 seconds
and then Nancy Pelosi literally cannot
get up just have an aide come and help
her to her feet and then she's joking
about it and laughing it's better not
have on I heels and smiling and laughing
oh wait these people take their
symbolism incredibly seriously this is
nuts
I'm sorry this is crazy and also even
the very symbolism of kneeling you know
who you should kneel before God a person
you're proposing to a person you've
sinned against but the idea for many of
those who are kneeling including
Democrats is that we are not guilty
they're kneeling because they're not
guilty they're kneeling because you're
guilty because if you're not kneeling
then you're not one of the woke you're
not one of the initiates right this is a
religious ritual and if you bow then
you're demonstrating you are part of the
initiative al well that is because you
are not demonstrating that you have
acquiesced and silence is violence gang
and then you have Joe Biden so Joe Biden
is is talking about George Floyd and
saying that George Floyd will change the
world as we're about to see Democrats
are perfectly willing to pander to the
radical aspirations of black lives
matter but then do nothing Joe Biden is
a key cog in this there was Joe Biden
talking about George Floyd yesterday on
CBS Evening News it's hard enough to
grieve but it's much harder to do it in
public
it's my Charter with the whole world
watching what an incredible family his
little daughter was there
I want to said daddy's going to change
the world and I think her daddy's going
to change the world I think what's
happened here is one of the great
inflection points in American history
for real in terms of civil liberties
civil rights and just treating people
with dignity so fair enough what does
that change look like so for Democrats
what it means that they posture as we're
about to see so Democrats don't actually
believe in any of the policy changes
that are being promoted we're gonna get
to that in just one second I mean what a
sucker's game politics is what a
sucker's game all you got to do is kneel
and put on a Kente cloth and pretend
that everybody who opposes you as a
racist and people will vote for you all
you have to do is keep repeating ad
nauseam that the police are the bad guys
and the rioters and looters are just
acting out of justified rage and people
will believe you all you have to do is
tell those protesters that you're on
their side then you don't have to do
anything they want you to do and then
they'll believe you but only if you're a
Democrat and only if you have the
media's backing it's pretty incredible
it's pretty incredible
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that you might be worried
out personal safety these days I know
here in Los Angeles
you know while people were sort of
rioting and looting and ransacking I was
sort of concerned about personal
security I know a lot of people were I
mean why not there's a footlocker three
blocks from us that was robbed there's
Walgreen three blocks from us that was
robbed and so I thought to myself you
know what it's a good thing that I know
what's happening on my property and
that's why I am very grateful for
ring.com ring is on a mission to make
neighborhood safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around the clock from video
doorbells and security cameras to smart
security lighting and alarm systems ring
has everything you need to make sure
your family and belongings are safe and
secure anytime anywhere with the all new
ring video doorbell three you can keep
it even closer eye on things than ever
before it's not a political statement to
say that you should be worried about
your family's safety and security at all
times this is true before the last few
weeks it's certainly gonna be true after
the next few weeks I mean you want to
make sure that people aren't wiping off
packages they deliver them to you not
sneezing directly on them in hand
ring can get this done for you get a
special offer on the ring welcome kit
when you go to ring accom slash been the
welcome kit includes the ring video
doorbell three and the chime pro that's
all you need to start building custom
security for your home today just go to
ring comm slash band that is ring.com
slash Ben go check them out right now
and make your home and your neighborhood
safer alrighty so you may have noticed
this this year news is insane and
depressing and wild and crazy it's a
roller coaster of just joy and and pain
it's unbelievable and your media are not
helping you because they are just won't
propagandas well if you need the reality
of the news what you really need is
readers pass from daily wire calm you'll
get access to exclusive op-eds from us
your podcast shows as well as guest
writers in-depth analyses from our daily
wire reporters on top of our regular
breaking news this membership tier is a
bargain at 3 bucks a month but if you
joined today you get your first month
for 99 cents you also get access to our
mobile app you receive push
notifications for breaking news and
special content and you can join the
community of daily wire members or
actively commenting and discussing our
content with each other that is mobile
ad free access to all of the daily where
news exclusive op-eds and more on our
mobile app all for the low price of one
dollar and best of all your dollars are
getting you the news you need without
the West to spin so head on over to
daily wire calm slash subscribe and join
today also now is a great time to
pre-order my book it is coming out July
21st it could not possibly be more
relevant and it's called how to destroy
in three easy steps the basic idea was
that there's a group of people in the
United States I called them this
integrationist would love to see the
Union come apart they would love to
shatter American philosophy they said
the Declaration of Independence is bad
and racist and so is the Constitution
they would love to shatter our history
and say we don't have a shared history
we just have a history of the exploiters
and the exploited and you are a member
of the exploiting class and they would
love to shatter our culture of rights
and say that our rights are in fact just
an outgrowth of our exploitative system
and the exercise of free speech and
freedom of the press exercise of free
association that all of these things are
actually just white supremacism I talk
about all of this in my book and I talk
about why all this is wrong and I talk
about what you can do to fight all of us
check out my new book it's coming out
July 21st it's available now for
pre-order at Amazon or anywhere else
books are sold how to destroy America in
three easy steps you're listening to the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say it is all about the
signaling it's not really about the
policies we're about to see so what does
this mean means that when Democrats hear
radical proposals they won't just
dismiss them but they're not gonna go
along with them and they actually have a
chance to vote on them so over the last
48 hours there's been a call to defund
the police and it's been fun to watch
the media spin on behalf of what defund
the police means do you fund the police
it turns out does not mean defund the
police it actually just means
fundamental health services well if
you'd said that in the first place
then I kind of would've been on board
right keep the funding for the police
expand the funding for the police and
also make sure that you actually have
services to take care of mentally ill
people which by the way I've been
stumping for on this program for
literally years I mean go back and
listen I've done full episodes on it on
the homeless problem in our major cities
for example but that's not what they
called for and the reason they didn't
call for that is because that's not sexy
slogan saying we need to spend more on
social services for the mentally ill and
for drug addicts that's not a sexy
slogan defund the police is the slogan
because even most radical protesters the
ones who are out chanting in the streets
want the police out of their communities
they're not being ambiguous about this
when when the Minneapolis Mayor who
spent the last couple of weeks begging
forgiveness for his whiteness from the
black lives matter crowd I mean
seriously that's what he did he
literally went in a crowd and he talked
about his own conflicts and trying to
expunge his own white guilt and all of
his nonsense and he was shirred for that
then he was asked you want to just get
rid of the police said I'm not for
abolishing the police and people started
shouting at him get the F out of here
and shame right so the protesters are
pretty obvious what they want the
Minneapolis City Council is even more
obvious they're not talking about just
defunding the city police and then
bringing in the county which is what
happened in Cam's in New Jersey bunch of
people keep saying well it's just like
cams and Camden New Jersey doubled the
size of its police force they're the
most the most over policed major city in
America right now they doubled the size
of the police force they just went from
the city to the county it was like 250
people now it's 411 people or policing
that area so don't tell me they defunded
the police they didn't they just shifted
responsibility for the police to the
county but Minneapolis went further they
said they wanted to completely
reorganize how policing is done period
but they obviously want to minimize the
police footprint so Lisa bender I played
this clip yesterday but is so
astonishing it really is indicative of
where the mindset is Lisa bender who is
the president of the Minneapolis City
Council she actually agreed yesterday
that police don't make the city safer
do not make the city safer now you
cannot you literally cannot name a case
in which this is true or removal of the
police has made city safer it does not
exist one of the most robust social
science findings ever is that when you
remove police from a situation criminals
run free
that's common sense everyone knows this
I have a perfect case in point for a
week the police were basically told
hands-off and what happened rioting
looting breaking into stores people
shattering windows damage to cop cars
that were out there on the streets then
the cities were like oh you know what we
actually can't tolerate this any longer
the National Guard came in the cops
showed up and what happened in two
nights it was over in two nights it was
over and by the way in areas where they
are not doing this Seattle and Portland
for example riding a mood and continue
it does not take a genius to recognize
that when you remove police from high
crime communities crime goes up not down
again one of the more robust social
science findings in American race
studies is that the removal of police
from black communities in the early 20th
century led to a radical rise in crime
which exacerbated inequality but
according to Lisa bender the president
of the Minneapolis City Council police
don't make the city safer they don't
wishful thinking and singing imagine
that's what makes the city safer here's
Lisa bender full-scale idiot yesterday
night City Council members stood
together with our community and pledged
to rethink public safety in our
community and to acknowledge that the
current Minneapolis Police Department is
not working to keep our community safe
and really what we pledged was to start
a year long conversation with
Minneapolis residents to help us
reimagine what public safety looks like
as we make those short-term fixes that
are so clearly needed in our department
that was the same lady who suggested
yesterday that if someone calls 911 to
she said the Senate Alison camerata that
if someone calls mine on one they should
check that privilege now you have to
check your priveledge for worried about
crime okay so here's the thing top
Democrats have been asked about this
defunded the police thing Pelosi and
Democrats were asked about the
Minneapolis city council defunding the
police and looking to basically destroy
the police department from within here
is a bevy of Democrats refusing to
criticize the Minneapolis City Council
for taking measures that obviously are
going to make matters worse in high
crime
[Music]
well I can't imagine that happening in a
Federal Way but let me just tell you
that part of that cry is a desire for
there to be significant higher
investment in communities I think the
congresswoman answers your question very
clearly but the fact is is that we do
have a great deal of legislation coming
down the pike that addresses some of the
concerns of our communities across the
country ok so this is an explicit
refusal to condemn that right and then
Kamala Harris was asked on the view
about defunding the police and she
refused to just say well actually when
we say defunding the police what we
don't mean is getting rid of the police
well we just mean is we're gonna shift
social services instead just dodged the
question from Meghan McCain and then of
course Twitter trended Meghan McCain
because Meghan McCain is very bad for
asking the most obvious question what
the hell do you mean by defunding the
police are you for defunding the police
how are you defining to fund the police
I assume it's removing police and as
congresswoman Ilhan Omar said bringing
in a whole new way of governing and a
law-and-order into into a community we
need to reimagine how we are achieving
public safety in America and to have
cities where one third of their entire
budget is going to policing but yet
there is a dire need in those same
cities for mental health resources for
resources going into public schools
resources going into job training and
job creation come on by the way spending
money on job training and job creation
is not going to stop criminality it
isn't it is not going to you need to
stop the crime so that people can invest
in communities you got this all
backwards the precondition to economic
growth is not pouring state money into a
particular area we have tried this a
thousand times and it always fails the
precondition to economic growth is a
safe and secure neighborhood and then
people bringing their money in that is
the bad otherwise you know what you see
all the taxpayers leaving is what do you
think this money comes from money
doesn't grow on trees okay so the
Democrats refusing to explicitly move
away from the deparment police program
because they want to again act on these
sort of
fiery the fire in the guts kind of
messaging of BLM meanwhile you have a
widely trafficked column by a woman
named Michelle Alexander over the near
times called America this is your chance
we must get it right this time or risk
losing our democracy forever and after
recommending a bunch of books about
about race in America the same litany
that you will see over at Amazon being
represented being represented by the
woek then she gets to her real message
which is we must fight for economic
justice and she calls for socialism and
then she quotes James Baldwin who's a
favorite saying the necessity for a form
of socialism is based on the observation
that the world's precent present
economic Arrangements doom most of the
world to misery which again is one of
the great lies in human history is that
socialism uplifts everybody while
capitalism dooms the world to misery
capitalism has lifted more than half the
globe out of abject poverty we have
reduced extreme poverty on planet Earth
by 80 percent since 1980 that's because
of capitalism not because of the rise of
socialism and then Michelle Alexander
talks about dr. King dr. Martin Luther
King being a socialist and wbw EB Dubois
founder of the n-double a-c-p
becoming a socialist and now Albert
Einstein and Helen Keller and Paul
Robeson all being socialist and/or
communist Robeson was actually was like
a fellow traveler with the Soviet
Communist for a time during the 1930s
and then she says no matter what you
think about Bernie Sanders as a man or
as a candidate and I wish you is much
better at addressing racial issues like
reparations we all owe him and countless
organizers a debt of gratitude Oh Dewey
Dewey and she says younger black people
seem to understand the neoliberal
democratic politics of the past will not
take us where we need to go and they
supported Mr Sanders by significant
margins in polls we must work to create
an economic system that benefits us all
not just the wealthy okay so we are
hearing calls for socialism we're
hearing calls for getting rid of the
police and we're hearing calls for
racial reparations leading The
Huffington Post yesterday was an article
about why we need racial reparations
right now so white Americans presumably
should be spending money on black
Americans even though those white
Americans never enslaved those black
Americans what should the policies be
well it would mean black Americans just
getting checks from different
organizations which of course is not
going to solve underlying problems in
many of these communities problems of
failing schools are not going to be
solve by spending more money we have
tried that problems of family breakdown
are not going to be solved with the
check that's been true
the white community is through in the
black community as well the idea that if
you just cancel black student that like
that's the biggest issue cancelling
black student debt right now the biggest
issue is that they're not enough black
people who are graduating from high
school we need to increase the number of
black Americans who are not dropping out
of high school I mean it seriously that
is a major gap in American life but
we're not going to address any of those
major gaps in American life because if
you want to talk about truly
uncomfortable conversations then you
have to talk about personal behavior
that results in disparate impact right
you can't just talk about tossing money
at problems or blaming white Americans
for all problems so here's here's where
it gets really cynical here's where it
gets really cynical so the Democrats
have been repeating all this they're
running they can't say cloths they're
kneeling they're repeating all of the
slogans they're suggesting the racist if
you don't back all of these all of these
movements that they're there expressing
sympathy for rioting and looting on
occasion they're expressing sympathy for
defund the police meanwhile Chicago
suffered its deadliest day in 60 years
at 18 murders in 24 hours this is
according to D isn D is our n calm May
31st alone 18 people that was murdered
on Sunday that was the most since 1961
the entire weekend stretching from May
29th through May 31st 24 people were
killed in Chicago another 85 were
wounded by gunfire nobody's gonna
remember any of these names and nobody's
willing to care because of course it
doesn't pack the narrative that America
that's a big threat to black America is
white police and so here's where the
rubber hits the road the Democrats they
mirror all the messaging and then when
it comes time for them to actually
mirror the policies like not we're not
doing any of that because they
understand they know these policies are
not geared toward helping people they
know that the policies that they
themselves are unwilling to condemn that
those policies are actually bad policies
so what they want is the message America
is deeply and systemically racist but
then they act in ways that do not
suggest that they actually believe that
the system is deeply systemically racist
they are not going to bet the Democrats
are in control of Congress have they
passed a bill on on slavery reparations
and what they think Americans should pay
of course not because they know that
first of all it's unjust and second it's
unpopular Democrats are in control of
Congress right now have they passed a
bill to defund police departments across
the country they have not in fact Joe
Biden who five seconds ago was saying
that George Floyd is going to change the
world which is all well and good he
rejected the
all for defunding the police openly
rejected the call for defunding police
here was here was Joe Biden actually
saying he's going to expand the funding
for the police
do you support defunding the police no I
don't support defunding the police
I support conditioning federal aid the
police based on whether or not they meet
certain basic standards of decency on
honorable list and in fact are able to
demonstrate they can protect the
community and everybody in the community
amazing so there he is basically saying
the same thing I'm saying about the
police and how the police are protecting
communities but as long as Joe Biden
signals then he's saying something very
different Stephanie rawlings-blake who
is I believe the former mayor of
Baltimore
I believe Stephanie rawlings-blake was
the person who suggested that she was
gonna give space for people to burn in
Baltimore back in 2014 when people were
riding she said we have to stop with
this call to defund the police it's just
giving Trump a talking point weird
because you on the left are giving our
humouring that's nonsense you're
humoring it and pretending like it's
legit because again what you want is the
broad message what you don't actually
want is the policy that follows from the
broad message as I've been talking about
for a week Democrats basically set a
controlled fire they push the narrative
than America systemically racist and
that if you oppose that narrative then
you are evil and racist yourself you
suffer from white privilege specifically
so they could pander for minority votes
and then when it comes time for policy
they're like you know what maybe you
could take this crumb here you can't set
that fire and hope to control it
Democrats sooner or later are gonna have
to move in line with the defund the
police crowd that's the prediction over
the next five years this will come a
mainstream call I'm old enough to
remember when Democrats said they
weren't in favor of nationalized health
care because that was crazy who would
say they were whatever is the outlined
position of the Democratic Party within
five years it becomes the mainstream
position inside the Democratic Party
watch it's gonna happen in real time say
here's Stephanie rawlings-blake saying
you know it's really damaging for us to
call to defund the police yes yes it is
but you know dance with the gala branya
by continuing to say defund dismantle we
are giving Trump talking points we are
feeding his base we all know that we can
do better when it comes to policing and
I think that it's a missed opportunity
not to figure out what better looks like
together and a path forward rather than
to again have this litmus test of you
know you're either foresight or against
us when it comes to dismantling the
police departments across the country so
what are Democrats actually pushing but
they're actually pushing they push for
the bill there are actual bill includes
reforms making it easier to sue police
officers from misconduct in civil court
so scaling back qualified immunity which
is something that has wide support and
prosecuting them for criminal behavior
it would also prohibit use of chokeholds
and certain no-knock warrants by police
nationwide again when it comes to
chokeholds you're gonna have to explain
whether you're talking about a chokehold
or a submission hold because sometimes
police do actually need to stop a
suspect from being violent and maybe the
best way to do that is to engage in a
submission hold the bill mandates the
use of body cameras which is fine it
creates a national database disclosing
the names of officers with a pattern of
abuse it would eliminate the legal
shield protecting police from lawsuits
hey these are all fairly mainstream
proposals you know what I'm not seeing
anything in here about defunding the
police not seeing anything in there
about defunding the police in fact House
Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
Republican said he can't comment on the
proposal cuz he hasn't seen the actual
language yet but he said that there are
three possible points of common ground
with Democrats he says I want to work
and see that we get law this is a moment
in time according to AP not included in
the bill is any nod toward the idea of
defunding the police or reallocating
police budgets toward other social
services such as housing at mental
health or substance abuse treatment
which some activists began calling for
over the weekend also noting about
reparations so bottom line is pander
pander pander pander pander that is the
bottom line here just complete and sole
pandering and if you buy this stuff
honestly if you buy that the Democrats
are on your side because they're
performative lis kneeling wearing kenton
cloths fine do it but you're a sucker
you're a sucker it's that simple
and meanwhile the the media continued to
abase themselves in front of the
American people it's pretty incredible
so America's newsrooms are being turned
over to the woke and it is an incredible
spectacle
it truly is Ben Smith had a piece of the
New York Times talking about how
newsrooms have decided they're gonna go
full editorial according to Ben Smith
he's the media reporter now over the New
York Times used to be the head of
BuzzFeed he says as America is wrestling
with the surging of a moment began
August 2014 it's biggest newsrooms are
trying to find common ground between a
tradition that aims to persuade the
widest possible audience that it's
reporting is neutral and journalists who
believe that fairness on issues from
races Donald Trump requires clear moral
calls now I'll be honest with you I'm in
favor the ladder I want all the masks
off I think that objective journalism is
a lie I think it's been a lie for a very
long time I think there are very few in
the journalistic worlds we even attempt
objective journalism a signal i-i've
singled out people that I think have
tried in the past I think Jake Tapper
try sometimes on Siena but I think that
the vast majority of reporters are not
reporters they're activists so I'm glad
that they are now being open about this
the conflict exploded in recent days
into public protests at the New York
Times ending in the resignation of its
top opinion editor on Sunday the
Philadelphia Inquirer whose executive
editor resigned on Saturday over the
headline buildings that matter to and
the ensuing anger from his staff the
Pittsburgh post-gazette
it's been the subject of quiet agony at
the Washington Post which Wesley Lowery
left earlier this year months after the
executive editor Martin Barron
threatened to fire him for expressing
his views on Twitter about race
journalism and other subjects Lowry's
views that news organizations quote core
value needs to be the truth not the
perception of objectivity I am so
confused by this what he really means
that his opinion should be treated as
truth and that objective fact should not
be reported to you because you might
make up your mind in a way he doesn't
like Wesley Lowery Lowery's view has
been winning in a series of battled many
over how to cover race heated Twitter
criticism helps retire euphemisms like
racially charged okay but sometimes
there's a difference in in perception of
whether a statement was racially charged
for whether it was racist so which is
more accurate that's an editorial
subjective decision the big outlets have
gradually awkwardly given ground using
racist and lie more freely especially
when describing Trump's behavior which
by the way has undercut their own
credibility because it turns out half
the time they're saying Trump is lying
he is not they're saying that his
implication is wrong but that the fact
that he said something like they never
treat Trump with the same sort of well
they treat Trump with a very different
level of disdain when it comes to his
prevarications than they do any other
politician on planet earth obviously the
time is now to remake its opinion
section after Senator Tom cotton is out
bad calling for the use of troops in
American cities infuriated the news from
last week again the euphemisms it called
for the use of troops to put down
rioting and looting in American cities
it wasn't just random
sending in soldiers meanwhile Axios has
decided that it's reporters are allowed
to join protests in a company memo the
chief executive of the politics news
site said he supported staff members
right to march adding the publisher
would cover bail for any employee who
was arrested for any employee so if you
chuck a rock at a cop and you work for
Axios they're now going to bail you out
Jim VandeHei the co-founder and chief
executive of axe yes at first let me say
we part we proudly support and encourage
you to exercise your rights to free
speech press and protest if you're
arrested or meet harm while exercising
these rights Axios will stand behind you
and use the family fund to cover your
bail or assist with medical bills that
was sent replied to an employee who had
been asked who had asked about the
company stance on protesting as part of
a weekly practice at Axios where staff
members anonymously submit questions to
managers exciting exciting stuff now
ethics guidelines at the new york times
say the company's journalists may not
march or rally in support of public
causes or movements or publicly take
positions on public issues adding doing
so might reasonably raise doubts about
their ability or the times ability to
function as neutral observers in
covering the news but obviously Axios
thinks differently so we are now
watching as the media basically stripped
the masks off themselves we on the right
of been saying for literally decades
you're a bunch of leftist activists
disguising yourselves as objective
journalist and I know how dare you we
are so objective we are journalism up
the wazoo journalism in everywhere down
lemon not an opinion die a Chris Cuomo
not an opinion guy a journalist Jim
Acosta not an opinion guy a journalist
we are just it's journalism guys it's
reporting and if you attack our opinions
you're attacking us as an institution on
the other hand on the other hand if we
wish to join protests and if we wish to
suggest that a point of view is out of
bounds even though it is a mainstream
American opinion like America is not
systemic ly racist and that America's
history of racism does not mean that
America today is institutionally racist
those opinions if we just dismiss them
as racist themselves that's also
objective journalism which means that
you've now redefined objective
journalism
also the revolution continues apace so
the real revolution is not happening in
terms of policy I mentioned the
Democrats are ignoring the policy
proposals put forward by black lives
matter but because they're patently
insane so just not going to do it
instead they've decided to take out
their rage the woke stirs have decided
to take out their rage at
liberal institutions they know they can
control they can't control Congress
because the Senate is held by
Republicans they can't even control
can't control Congress because despite
the vast size of these protests and all
of the virtuous signaling you see online
the vast majority of Americans are not
in favor of defunding the police the
vast majority of Americans are not in
favor of slavery reparations or
remoulding the American economy along
socialist lines most Americans don't
like this Democrats know this Democrats
are answerable not just to the Twitter
mob they are answerable to their own
constituents so they're not gonna
they're not gonna get with anyone from
Congress what they're gonna get from
Congress is a bunch of idiotic virtue
signaling that's what they're gonna get
so where can they actually get results
ah they can get results in the world of
the media they get results in the world
of sports in the cultural sphere they
can get results by making drew breezes
wife apologize for the great set of her
husband having stood up for the American
flag they can get results from bone
Appetit magazine very important the
editor-in-chief of bone Appetit is a man
named Adam Rapoport he resigned on
Monday after a photo of him in brown
face resurfaced from 2013 it was him
dressed up as apparently a Puerto Rican
many former and current bon appetit
staffers called for Rapoport to resign
after the photo was posted to Twitter by
food writer Tammy to clam areum very
very important that this guy lose his
job in his career because he went to a
Halloween party
very very important stuff obviously
supposed to be obviously he's a vicious
racist clearly he's a vicious racist
Rappaport said he had not champion an
inclusive vision I mean this is malice
stuff they put him out in the public
square hang a sign around his neck I'm a
racist resign from your job it's the
Cultural Revolution in real time it's
good times
he said ultimately it's been at the
expense of bone Appetit in its staff as
well as our readers they all deserve
better you're a food magazine what are
you are you a racist food magazine and
I'm confused
the staff has been working hard to
evolve the brands in a positive more
diverse direction I will do all I can to
support that work but I'm not the one to
lead the work I'm not the one to lead
the work it was deeply important that he
stepped down very very important stuff
great stuff right there it's it this
this is the way that that everything is
going to work because the media is
susceptible to this sort of stuff and
then bone Appetit put out a put out the
black square right the black lives
matter a black square which is white
text on a black background if you do
that anything you're right in the text
is virtuous this is something that we
know from online we know from my mind is
you could literally just put anything
they can put the starwars crawl in white
text on a black background is now
virtuous and well they wrote food has
always been political but has it really
like always has it so much
sure sure everything is political every
single thing is political by the way if
you mentioned that everything is
political and it's annoying then you get
trended on Twitter that's the that's the
idea here meanwhile what they're not
just going after by the way food is so
political that they didn't just go after
the editor of Bon Appetit his women in
Ellison Roman who was forced to
apologize she wrote a New York Times
bestseller nothing fancy and she was a
columnist for New York Times cooking I'm
gonna say was I have a feeling that
she's probably not going to be for much
longer why well because when she was 23
she did a Halloween party in which she
dressed up as in an Amy Winehouse
costume she had big hoop earrings but
Allison Romans white if you were a big
hoop earrings hoop earrings are for
Latinas I'm dead serious this is a thing
that happened is it is a thing that
happened she wore a a costume in which
he had big hoop earrings on and as we
know only Latino women wear hoop
earrings and so Allison Roman is now
canceled she tweeted out in apology this
incredibly embarrassing picture was
taken in 2008 you're just wearing hoop
earrings lady I was 23 and living in San
Francisco this was my San Francisco
inspired Amy Winehouse costume for
Halloween
it reads it's culturally insensitive and
I was an idiot child who knew nothing
about the world how this would be
perceived and I'm sorry no there shall
be no repentance you shall be cast out
into the wilderness and cast from a
cliff that's the way it works in the
world of media and results have been
achieved
racism is being solved in real time guys
it's being solved another medal a Jimmy
Kimmel gets to keep his job despite
having dressed up in blackface as Carl
Malone way back when he's okay totally
fine but Alison Roman very very evil
here's the thing it's never gonna be
enough because once you're in the
culturally woke sphere it's never enough
none of its ever enough every you can
you can bend the knee you're not gonna
be treated as a person who is now
absolved of your saying
you're going to be treated as a person
who ought to have their head lopped off
Joffrey style you can mean that start
and accept your expulsion to the
Nightwatch
you can but guess what you ain't going
to the Nightwatch my friend you're going
to a very different place the whoa crowd
is out for heads and they're going to
get heads and the best way they can do
that is by targeting the media because
the media are incredibly responsive to
this sort of stuff many corporations are
incredibly responsive to this stuff
because they're risk-averse and their
controversy over the left knows this
this is why the left is is ruining
culture a pace this is what they are
doing so prepare for it and everybody
everybody who's working right now in
America and is receiving notes from
their employers about how they bared
guilt for George Floyd's death is
feeling this right now and if you speak
up and say wait I didn't kill George
Floyd I think it was evil what do I have
to do with this ah you're not culturally
sensitive you're a white supremacy
you're secretly racist deep down most
Americans know this is crap most
Americans know they're not bad people
most Americans know they're not racist
most Americans know they post police
brutality and racism most Americans know
that and that's why the longer this goes
on the less it's going to achieve
seriously because in terms of policy and
in achieving anything and in terms of
actually changing Americans minds I'm
wondering how you change Americans minds
by by basically castigating people who
are not racist as racist for not saying
the specific words you want and then by
putting out videos of people kneeling
before other people not sure how that is
a good idea all right we'll be back here
later today with two additional hours of
content otherwise we will see you here
tomorrow also I have an all-access
tonight so if you subscribe over at
daily wire.com and you become an
all-access subscriber then you too can
join in the fun you can ask me questions
over the Q&A I wear t-shirts which of
course is the big pitch otherwise we'll
see you here same time same bat-channel
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas executive producer Jeremy
boring supervising producer Mathis
Glover and Robert Stirling assistant
director Pavel why douse key technical
producer austin stevens playback and
media operated by Nick Sheehan associate
producer Katie Swinton edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
Chuck and Nancy solve racism by wearing
African scarves though frankly I think
they need to go full dashiki if they
really want to fix the problem the
experts get coronavirus completely wrong
again and the Minneapolis City Council
president wants you to check your
privilege of being able to call 911 and
emergency all that more check it out on
the Michael Nolt show
[Music]